[Musique]
nous te saluons camarades nous tes amis
tes frères et soeurs de classes
préparatoires de l'université des
premiers pas dans le métier de
professeur d'histoire et de géographie
le 15 janvier 1888 dans la dépêche de
toulouse jean jaurès écrit aux
instituteurs et institutrices quelques
conseils pour que les élèves apprennent
à être autonome à réfléchir à se forger
une opinion conseil auquel samuel tu as
été fidèle vous tenez dans vos mains
l'intelligence et l'âme des enfants
vous êtes responsable de la patrie
les enfants qui vous sont confiés
n'auront pas seulement à écrire et à
déchiffrer une lettre à lire une
enseigne au coin d'une rue à faire une
addition d une multiplication ils sont
français ils doivent connaître la france
sa géographie et son histoire son corps
et son âme
ils seront citoyens
ils doivent savoir ce qu'est une
démocratie libre quel droit leur confère
qu'elle de voir leur impose la
souveraineté de la nation
enfin ils seront homme et il faut qu'ils
aient une idée de l'homme
il faut qu'ils sachent quelle est la
racine de toutes nos misères l'égoïsme
aux formes multiples il faut qu'ils
sachent quel est le principe de notre
grandeur la fierté unis à la tendresse
il faut leur montrer la grandeur de la
pensée il faut leur enseigner le respect
et le culte de l'âme en éveillant en eu
le sentiment de l'infini qui est notre
joie est aussi notre force
car c'est par lui que nous trions feront
du mal de l'obscurité et de la mort
sachant bien lire les colliers trek est
très curieux aurait bien vite avec sept
ou huit livres choisis une idée très
générale il est vrai mais très hot de
l'espèce humaine de la structure du
monde de l'histoire propre de la terre
dans le monde du rôle propre de la
france dans l'humanité le maître doit
intervenir pour aider ce premier travail
de l'esprit
il n'est pas nécessaire qu'ils disent
beaucoup qu'il fasse de l'ombre le sont
il suffit que tous les détails qui leur
donnera concours nettement un tableau
d'ensemble de ce que l'on sait de
l'homme primitif à l'homme d'aujourd'hui
quel prodigieuse transformation et comme
il est aisé à l'instituteur et aux
professeurs en quelques traits de faire
sentir à l'enfant
l'effort inouïe de la pensée humaine je
dis donc au maître et aux professeurs
pour me résumer lorsque d'une part vous
aurez appris aux enfants à lire à fond
et lorsque d'autre part en quelques
causerie familière et grave
vous leur aurez parler de grandes choses
qui intéressent la pensée et la
conscience humaine
vous aurez sans peine en quelques années
fait oeuvre complète d'éducateurs dans
chaque intelligence il y aura un sommet
et ce jour là bien des choses changeront
adieu samuel
oh
à samuel pâtit
paraît qu'on s'habitue aux larmes de la
nation ce matin on s'est tu sous le coup
de l'émotion paraît qu'on s'habitue
quand la femme est légion tous ces
hommes abattus pour les traits d'un
crayon paraît qu'on s'habitue à défendre
à tout prix les trois mots qu'on a lues
au fronton des mairies paraît qu'on
s'habitue
quand on manque de savoir par chance on
a tous eu un professeur d'histoire
paraît qu'on s'habitue à la pire
barbarie mais jamais on ya cru et pas
plus aujourd'hui paraît qu'on s'habitue
aux horreurs qu'on vit là mais
l'innocent qu'on tue on ne s'habitue pas
lettre de camus à son instituteur louis
germans écrite le jour où il a reçu le
prix nobel de littérature 19 novembre
cher monsieur germain je laisser
s'éteindre un peu le bruit qui m'a
entouré de ces jours ci avant de venir
vous parler un peu de tout mon coeur on
vient de me faire un bien trop grand
honneur que je n'ai ni à rechercher ni
sollicitée mais quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle
ma première pensée après ma mère a été
pour vous sans vous sans cette main
affectueuse que vous avez tendu au petit
enfant pauvre que je su que j'étais sans
votre enseignement et votre exemple
rien de tout cela ne serait arrivé je ne
me fais pas un monde de cette sorte
d'honneur mais celui là est du moins une
occasion pour vous dire ce que vous avez
été et est toujours pour moi et pour
vous assurer que vos efforts votre
travail et le coeur généreux que vous y
mettiez sont toujours vivants chez un de
vos petits écoliers qui malgré l'âge n'a
pas cessé d'être vous revu votre
reconnaissante élèves
je vous embrasse de toutes mes forces
albert camus
mesdames
messieurs ce soir je n'aurai pas de mot
pour évoquer la lutte contre l'islamisme
politique radicale qui mène jusqu'au
terrorisme les mots je les ai eu le mal
je les nommer les actions nous les avons
décidé nous les avons durci nous les
mènerons jusqu'au beau ce soir je ne
parlerai pas du cortège de terroristes
de leurs complices et de tous les lâches
qui ont commis les rendu possible cet
attentat je ne parlerai pas de ceux qui
ont livré son nom aux barbares ils ne le
méritent pas de nom eux n'ont même plus
ce soir je ne parlerai pas davantage de
l'indispensable unité que toutes les
françaises et tous les français
ressentent
elle est précieuse et oblige tous les
responsables à s'exprimer avec justesse
et à agir avec exigence non ce soir
je veux parler de votre fils je veux
parler de votre frère de votre oncle de
celui que vous avez aimé de ton père ce
soir je veux parler de votre collègue de
votre professeur tomber parce qu'il
avait fait le choix d'enseignés
assassiné parce qu'il avait décidé
d'apprendre à ses élèves à devenir
citoyens à prendre les devoirs pour les
remplir à prendre les libertés pour les
exercer ce soir je veux vous parler
de samuel pâtit samuel pâtit aimer les
livres le savoir plus que tout son
appartement était une bibliothèque c'est
plus beau cadeau des livres pour
apprendre
il aimait les livres pour transmettre à
ses élèves comme à ses proches
la passion de la connaissance le goût de
la liberté
après avoir étudié l'histoire à lyon et
avoir envisagé devenir chercheur il
avait emprunté la voie tracée par vous
séparant instituteur et directeur
d'école à moulins en devenant chercheurs
en pédagogie comme il aimait à se
définir en devenant professeur aussi
nous pouvait-on trouver meilleur endroit
que la sorbonne notre lieu de savoir
universel depuis + de vie siècle le lieu
de l'humanisme pour que la nation puisse
lui rendre cet hommage
samuel bâti aimé passionnément enseigné
il le fit si bien dans plusieurs
collèges et lycées jusqu'à celui de
conflans sainte honorine
nous avons tous ancrés dans nos coeurs
dans nos mémoires le souvenir d'un
professeur qui a changé le cours de
notre existence
vous savez cet instituteur qui nous a
appris à lire à compter à nous faire
confiance
cet enseignant qui nous a pas seulement
a pris un savoir mais nous a ouvert un
chemin par un livre un regard un instant
passé par sa considération
samuel pâtit était de ceux-là de ses
professeurs que l'on n'oublie pas
de ces passionnés capables de passer des
nuits à apprendre l'histoire des
religions pour mieux comprendre ses
élèves leurs croyances
de ses humbles qui se remettait mille
fois en question comme pour ce cours sur
la liberté d'expression la liberté de
conscience qu'il préparait depuis
juillet encore l'été dernier à moulins à
vos côtés et des doutes qu'il partageait
par exigence par délicatesse
samuel pâtit incarner au fond le
professeur dont rêvait jaurès dans cette
lettre aux instituteurs qui vient d'être
lu la fermeté unis à la tendresse celui
qui montre la grandeur de la pensée
enseigne le respect d'un à voir ce
qu'est la civilisation
celui qui s'était donné pour tâche de
faire des républicains alors reviennent
comme en écho les mots de fer non
buisson pour faire un républicain
écrivait-il
il faut prendre l'être humain si petit
et si humble qu'il soit il lui donner
l'idée qu'il faut penser par lui-même
qu'il ne doit ni foi ni obéissance à
personne que c'était lui de chercher la
vérité et non pas à la recevoir toute
faite d'un mètre d'un directeur d'un
chef
quel qu'il soit faire
des républicains c'était le combat de
samuel bâti et si cette tâche
aujourd'hui peut paraître titanesque
notamment là où la violence
l'intimidation
parfois la résignation prennent le
dessus
elle est plus essentielle plus actuelle
que jamais ici en france nous aimons
notre nation sa géographie ses paysages
et son histoire sa culture et ses
métamorphoses son esprit et son coeur et
nous voulons l'enseigné à tous nos
enfants ici en france nous aimons le
projet tout à la fois
therrien et universel que porte la
république son ordre et ses promesses
chaque jour recommencer alors oui dans
chaque école dans chaque collège dans
chaque lycée
nous redonnerons aux professeurs le
pouvoir de faire des républicains la
place et l'autorité qui leur reviennent
nous les formerons les considérons comme
il se doit nous les soutiendrons nous
les protégerons autant qu'il le faudra
dans l'école comme hors de l'école les
pressions l'abus d'ignorance et
d'obéissance que certains voudraient
instaurer n'ont pas leur place chez nous
je voudrais que ma vie et ma mort serve
à quelque chose avait il dit un jour
comme par prescience alors pourquoi
samuel futile tués
pourquoi
vendredi soir
j'ai d'abord cru à la folie aléatoire à
l'arbitraire absurde une victime de plus
du terrorisme gratuit après tout il
n'était pas la cible principale des
islamistes il ne faisait qu enseigner il
n'était pas l'ennemi de la religion dont
ils se servent ils avaient lu le coran
est respecté ses élèves quelles que
soient leurs croyances
il s'intéressait à la civilisation
musulmane non tout au contraire
samuel pâtit fut tué précisément pour
tout cela parce qu'ils incarnaient
la république qui renaît chaque jour
dans les salles de classe la liberté qui
se transmet et se perpétue à l'école
samuel pâtit fille tuée parce que les
islamistes veulent notre futur et qu'ils
savent qu'avec des héros tranquille tels
que lui ils ne l'auront jamais eu
c'est par les fidèles et les mécréants
samuel pâtit ne connaissait que des
citoyens eux se repaissent de
l'ignorance lui croyait dans le savoir
eux cultivent la haine de l'autre
lui voulait sans cesse en voir le visage
découvrir les richesses de l'altérité
samuel bâti fut la victime de la
conspiration funeste de la bêtise du
mensonge de la malle gamme de la haine
de l'autre de la haine de ceux que
profondément existentiellement nous
sommes samuel pathé est devenu vendredi
le visage de la république de notre
volonté de briser les terroristes de
réduire les islamistes de vivre comme
une communauté de citoyens libres dans
notre pays
le visage de notre détermination à
comprendre à apprendre a continué
d'enseigner à être libre
car nous continuerons professeurs nous
défendrons la liberté que vous enseignez
si bien et nous porterons pour la
laïcité
nous ne renoncerons pas aux caricatures
au dessin même si d'autres reculs nous
offriront toutes les chances que la
république doit à toute sa jeunesse sans
discrimination aucune
nous continuerons professeurs avec tous
les instituteurs et professeurs de
france nous enseignerons l'histoire ces
gloires comme ces vicissitudes nous
feront découvrir la littérature la
musique
toutes les oeuvres de l'âme et de
l'esprit
nous aimerons de toutes nos forces le
débat les arguments raisonnables les
persuasion aimable nous aimerons la
science et ses controverses comme vous
nous cultiverons la tolérance comme vaud
nous chercherons à comprendre sans
relâche et à comprendre encore davantage
cela qu'on voudrait éloigné de nous nous
apprendrons l'humour la distance
nous rappellerons
que nos libertés ne tiennent que par la
fin de la haine et de la violence par le
respect de l'autre nous continuerons
professeurs
et tout au long de leur vie
les centaines de jeunes gens que vous
avez formé exerceront cet esprit
critique que vous leur avez appris
peut-être certains d'entre eux
deviendront ils enseignants à leur tour
alors ils formeront des jeunes citoyens
à leur tour ils feront aimer la
république
ils feront comprendre notre nation nos
valeurs notre europe dans une chaîne des
temps qui ne s'arrêtera pas nous
continuerons oui ce combat pour la
liberté et pour la raison dont vous êtes
désormais le visage parce que nous vous
le devons parce que
nous nous le devons parce qu'en france
professeur les lumières ne s'éteignent
jamais vive la république
vive la france